sometimes you just need to hear an old
joke told in a different way
[Applause]
[Music]
so this joaquin phoenix joker movie
thing that i very seriously would not
have called was actually going to get
made this is pulling together really
quickly and as we have gotten a fairly
steady drip of stuff over the last no
less the little less than a week but you
know we got our first look at Joaquin
Phoenix's character you know prior to
Joker makeup then we saw a screen a
screen test where we got to look at what
he looked like in makeup and then some
footage leaked of you know a subway
scene so there's been a bit you have not
a ton of official but kind of a steady
drip feet of things that are starting to
create I don't want to say a clearer
picture but a picture and one that I am
finding increasingly intriguing so my
initial thoughts a while ago and this
thing was first being batted around were
it's not a bad idea but it's probably
not a good time and my basis for feeling
that was that at the time it was
announced you know justice league hadn't
come out yet things were very much in a
state of it's super unclear where things
are going and DC was still very much
trying to be like no we have a plan
we're building a coherent universe at
this point that really feels like it's
gone out the window and it's it's much
more look we're just gonna we're just
gonna get movies out there and figure
out what works although in an odd way it
feels a little less desperate now than
it might have otherwise because I think
we're we're seeing them not get hung up
on the continuity which i think is is a
good thing but when I had said initially
you know not a bad idea but the wrong
time it struck me because basically I'm
treating this like in Elseworlds which
if you don't know you know DC Comics
that's what they call basically any
story that is completely outside of
continuity and you know which which
frees it up to do crazy wild things like
Gotham by Gaslight which was steampunk
Batman that's kind of thought of as the
original Elseworlds and then things like
that so thinking of this as an
Elseworlds movie that struck me as like
okay it's not a bad idea but maybe you
should have a stronger foundation for
what your main universe is before you do
that but now seeing like see you knowing
the state of the the DC continuity which
could very easily just get blown up if
if Aquaman if Aquaman does poorly
they'll keep wondering when we're going
and they're probably gonna scrap
everything else but like would that so
being in a state of flux you know what
why not do this weird oddball thing and
I real there's a number of things that I
really like and I really find intriguing
about this first of all I like that it's
a it's a much smaller budget it's a
fifty five million dollar movie the
thing is the funny thing about movies at
that budget range they don't get made
very often anymore pretty much the
budget range these days it's either
tentpole blockbusters you know you're
150 million dollar-plus movies or
they're your tightly contained films
either like indie films or things like
bloom house which does really um tightly
contained horror movies on like 10
million dollar budgets nobody reliably
does mid budget anymore which is a shame
because this mid budget is where you're
it's where you're spending enough money
to to be able to do some interesting
things but not spending so much where
there's gonna be a ton of high-end
executive oversight either because
that's always kind of the danger with
the big temple blockbusters where you
spending that much money the people at
the top are really gonna be scrutinizing
all the parts of it where is something
on this mid-tier not so much I mean like
the last I'd say notable mid-tier
budgeted movie we had was the first
Deadpool
even that that was kind of by
circumstance rather by choice the Fox
was prepared to spend more money on it
but only if they didn't go r-rated so
when they existed on our a that went
fine you're not getting what normally
would have been considered a proper
sized budget for what that movie was
trying to be so I like that it I like
the the range that it's being made in
Joaquin Phoenix as a performer I think
he's an incredibly talented performer he
doesn't he doesn't often do movies that
have a ton of appeal to me so like I I
don't have a serious opinion on him
besides thinking that he is a good actor
I do believe that but like I don't have
a very committed opinion because he he
it's been a long time since he's done
something that I actually saw because he
doesn't tend to do movies that I like
which is fine the director and that's a
little bit more Effie although I do like
that Scorsese is producing that's very
cool and I like that they've kind of
cited taxi driver as sort of the
thematic influence and from what we've
seen what little we've seen that makes
sense we sort of the the first image we
got of Joaquin Phoenix without you know
any Joker makeup on you know this is a
an aging guy who's probably just spent
most of his life not really getting
anywhere and then just the grin that he
has when he has the Joker makeup and the
Joker makeup like I can see we're
purists might be like that's all wrong
but I kind of I kind of like it is like
I would never want that to be the makeup
of your primary continuity Joker either
in film or in comics or any of that I'm
like I wouldn't want to look at it that
much but if you're gonna do something
this far you know out of what is
standard for the Joker why not I mean
the fact that you're gonna cover the
Joker's origin anyway is kind of outside
the norm and I know that sounds weird
because like the first major Hollywood
film for Batman Batman 89 they did cover
the Joker's origin but if you need to
how weird that is because one of the
Joker's primary features is that we
don't have a definitive origin for him
that's kind of one of the things that's
really ingrained in him that we don't
know for sure what his name was who he
was what he did what made him go mad we
don't know we have a ton of options with
a ton of theories ton of possibilities
some even you know fairly likely but we
don't know for certain that's one of the
things that's cool about but you know if
you're gonna go the direction of here's
a definitive origin for at least a
version of the Joker you're already
playing kind of outside of the normal
way that you do this character and
assuming that there's no Batman which is
the pitch on the thing yeah just you
know what go don't feel so tied down
because there are tons of ways to honor
that I mean one of the fun things about
the Joker is he's a very malleable
character like I've never I've actually
yet to see a version of the Joker I'm
like that's wrong because the Joker can
be almost anything there are versions
that I prefer but even the jared leto
Joker who I don't really like I can't
say that's an invalid direction to take
the Joker and that still works cuz
that's yeah that's still that's still
Joker that is that is a you know madcap
modern sort of Miami style gangster
version of Joker but yeah that's as
valid as new are Joker from 89 Batman
from agent of chaos Joker from The Dark
Knight the the you know that the Mark
Hamill Joker the guy who is really
actually very it puts a lot of emphasis
on the performance and the jokes of what
he does you know all of the Cesar Romero
being the more goofy kind of trickster
all of these are valid all of these are
ways to do the Joker so I'm I'm becoming
increasingly intrigued I'm not gonna say
I'm hyped because the whole lump is
really hard for me to get hyped up about
any of the DC movies just because the
whole birthing process of this cycle of
DC films has been
so difficult and so many stumbles along
the way it's it's really hard for me to
get excited about any of the life I can
be hopeful I'm hopeful about a fair
number of them but it's hard for me to
get genuinely excited this one though I
think I'm is the one I'm most intrigued
by for the stuff that's being worked on
I just find it really interesting the
ideas that they seem to be working with
they're working with a budget that
should allow them to get away with
delivering whatever it is they're
planning to do and so rather than me
having to worry about oh my god is the
studio gonna come in and mess with this
and like insist on a bunch of notes that
are gonna make things worse which
happened on things like Batman vs
Superman and absolutely Justice League
and Suicide Squad and you know the the
studio coming in and interfering didn't
necessarily isn't necessarily the reason
those movies were bad I think in most of
those cases the movie that they were
messing with probably wasn't that good
in the first place but they made the
situation worse and what whatever we got
in the cases of those movies was not
what was originally planned try
intending to be made by the people who
actually made the dang thing whereas
here I think they're working on a budget
range and us and I think would the name
of somebody like Scorsese shepherding it
we are the very least going to get
whatever the intended vision is so now
it's just on that vision to be good
which is still no small feat but it's
much more doable knowing that it's not
gonna have that level of interference or
that level of oversight or at least I
don't expect that it will I'm not gonna
like super analyze the subway scene that
leaked I'm like I'm trying to figure out
what's going on there's like a ton of
people in various sort of clown outfits
that there seems to be like there seems
to be like a building sense of of chaos
and Anarchy going on and in the area and
the Joker is either instigating it or at
the very least feeding off of it but
again I do
I like that grin that that hulking
Phoenix gets its that is that is a very
satisfied grin that's and that's that's
a good way I think to go with with this
kind of Joker if
are doing a taxi-driver style story
where he's he's cutting loose he is this
this new form of himself is him just
getting to let all this stuff out and
find something that gives him a very
perverse kind of joy and I think that
that can work really really really well
so yeah I'm oddly hopeful about this for
something that I was super skeptical of
previously I'm gonna be keeping an eye
on and I will be really curious to see
see a first trailer certainly were a
ways off from that they've only just
started shooting the thing but you know
in I don't know six months or whatever
when we get a first trailer I I will be
right there I'll be real curious so
those are my thoughts on what we've
gotten so far with this Joaquin Phoenix
Joker thing that's happening so what are
your thoughts whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
stuff you can do cuz there's buttons and
there's links down below take a look at
them if you feel like it there's a link
to the patreon but if you don't want to
don't worry about it just remember folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]